- [ Interviewer] All right, Johnny Dollar,
Johnny, where are you from?
Where'd you grow up?
- [Johnny] I grew Up in a place called
Illinois Alton.
- [Interviewer] Where are you based now?
- [ Johnny] Mainly in Florida.
- [Interviewer] Minneapolis?
- [Johnny] Yes, sir.
- [Interviewer] Okay. And
tell me about your childhood.
You had both of your parents as a kid?
- [Johnny] Um Well, I have my mom, she was
she raised us both seven kids.
(sips the drink)
- [Interviewer] And how would you describe
your childhood?
- [Johnny] It was great, I had everything
I might have wanted.
- [Interviewer] Dad
was out of the picture?
- [Johnny] Excuse me.?
- [Interviewer] Your dad was not part
of your life?
- [Johnny] No, not really.
Not really.
I've seen him, you know
he bought me a little stuff
when I was young, you know
but he really wasn't there.
- [Interviewer] Um.
So you got introduced
to the game at what age?
- [Johnny] 16.
- [Interviewer] 16. And
how did that go down?
- [Johnny] I moved to
a place called Michigan
and I met a girl yesterday.
She was 28 years old
and I was 60 years old
and she really liked what was going on.
- [Interviewer] How did things start?
- [Johnny] Well, we fooled
around for a couple of years,
you know
and you know, she, she was a veteran.
She was really, really seasoned.
You know what I mean?
And she paid me a little
money, bought me a few outfits
bought me a car and things.
She knows she really
really wanted to mess with me, you know?
So that's how that went.
And I took her from
there to New York City.
- [Interviewer] And how many girls
did you have at once?
- [Johnny] I may have four or five deep.
- [Interviewer] And
you're still active today?
- [Johnny] Absolutely.
- [Interviewer] So what
does the pimp provide
to the girls? So you're
providing protection?,
You're managing their money?
- [Johnny] No, I, I, I provide knowledge.
That's going to carry them
through the lifetime, you know
after I'm dead and gone, the
knowledge that they've received
off of me, by being around me,
it carries them on through.
They really get a lot of ism.
- [Interviewer] And where,
what does the girl get out of it?
- [Johnny] Oh, they have everything
just like I have.
Yeah, they have diamond rings,
line jeans and silk
suits and lizard boots.
They have it just like I do.
I don't want to see mine.
No, other than me, I want,
when they see my girls
I want them to see them shop
where they say, you know
it represents me and it says a lot.
- [Interviewer] And the money they make,
they give to you.
- [Johnny] Absolutely.
But now I give, I give just like I receive
I take care of them.
I make sure they have cars,
their hair did, you know
shoes and you know, all
the things that they need
I can kind of like guide them to stay
out of trouble, you know
to deal with the right people,
the upper scale people.
I try to keep them out there.
You know, the bad part of the game.
- [Interviewer] That's where your,
your expertise comes in.
- [Johnny] Excuse me?
- [Interviewer] Your expertise.
- [Johnny] Yes. Yes, yes, yes.
- [Interviewer] Have you
ever done prison time?
- [Johnny] Yeah. I've
been in prison before.
- [Interviewer] What was that for?
- [Johnny] Pimping and
pattern in San Diego.
- [Interviewer] And your
girls are what races?
- [Johnny] All, races.
They come going, you know, all flavors
I'm not prejudice or racist.
I like them all, you know, as long
as they pay it, they, they,
they could do a little laying.
- [Interviewer] And you
have sex with your girls?
- [Johnny] Sometimes.
- [Interviewer] Sometimes.
And what about drugs?
- [Johnny] When they deserve it?
- (man chuckles)
- [Interviewer] And what about drugs?
- [Johnny] Well, I don't,
I like weed, and I drink champagne.
You dig?.
That's all I want as a
woman to fall on my feet.
Anything else is no good
and it bring me down.
- [Interviewer] Right.
(Johnny sips the drink)
- [Johnny] But now there's
some out there they do do it
but they don't last with me.
- [Interviewer] What is your style?
You know, there's, there's
many different ways
of um types of many different styles
styles some use intimidation,
some,
- [Johnny] I'm a finesse pimp.
And really, I just don't, you know
I really don't like using
the word pimp, you know
cause I don't really pimp
no more, but you know
I got a lot of females
that helps me, you know
I was kind of like smart
and sharp in the game.
You know, I took out my
whole dollars and I invested
in a limousine company now I
own my own limousine company.
And I don't have to, you know
wait on my bus to come in and say
the trick ran off with the money,
Or I went to sleep,
He didn't pay me, you know
the buses gonna come in with that money
and the limos going to come here with it,
you know but I have a lot
of female to help me too.
- [Interviewer] And what's,
what's more important
to you, love or money.
- [Johnny] Money's more important to me.
Money is the root of all evil.
I love money.
You know, I know what to do with it.
And that's where a lot
of people admire me for
because I know how to invest my money
in the right places, you know?
And that's a good thing in life.
What I learned off an
older guy, I always raised
by the older guys, you
understand, because they're dead
and gone now knock on wood, rest in peace.
But I take pride of the game
and I take part of this
other game, you know
that they didn't taught
me and I mix it up.
You know what I mean?
And it lasts a lifetime.
I'll be 60 years old Friday.
- [Interviewer] Oh Happy Birthday.
- [Johnny] And that's a blessing
to be at that age.
But I have so much knowledge.
I have 80 year old knowledge
because I'm a people that I
was turnt out by that, you know
gave me a game you know, they
they're dead and gone, you know,
but their game, carried on.
And I have so many females
across this United States
that I've showed the game to,
and they're still living right now.
And they're making money.
They have own homes, cribs and everything.
I'm not with them now what,
you know, they advance.
And that's what I, I can't be mad.
And that's what they do.
Once they branch off of me,
they keep all getting money
but they manage their own money.
And they kind like, it's kind
of hard for me to get it now
but I just don't get the blessing
that I've taught them that showed
down and able to make it work right now.
They raise their kids.
They do it all.
- That's good.
- [Interviewer] I've
heard from a lot of the
girls and that sometimes
there's a little more
than just sex for money.
Sometimes there's trying to
figure out ways to get a watch
or some money out of the guy's wallet
that he may have, you know, from the trip.
- [Johnny] That's what the
other guys, I mean, you know
I don't really condone on them.
You know the thieves,
you know what I mean?
But it, a game it do happen.
You have thieves, you know,
they come into your life
but I don't condone on that.
I have my girls, on focus.
I make them focus on
catching sugar daddies.
And in Minnesota is a whole
lot of them, you know?
So they have like three
different sugar daddies where
they could see twice a week,
you know, three times a week.
And they ain't giving them no change.
They're giving them real paper.
You dig? Yeah Stacks on top of stacks.
It's more like a having,
It's like they girlfriend
that's what they think
is their girlfriend.
You know, something like that.
And I just keep it like that.
You know?
I'm not no jealous person.
- Wait, what kind of
girls do you look for?
- I look for the honest ones.
The one's that loyal,
you know, you gotta mess
with the girl that like
you, not the one you like
the one you like then
You're going to hear *beep.
Hell Nah, maybe later.
But the one that like you
you'll never hear him say no
it's easy, more, easier
to function and operate
With them.
- [Interviewer] What's the longest
one of your girls has been with you?
- [Johnny] I always get a
five or 10, seven, eight
nine year run out of it.
- [Interviewer] That's great.
- [Johnny] I have one Now
I've had a 30 year run out
of.
- [Interviewer] Wow. And what is the basis
of the pimp and prostitute
relationship is it?
She needs to like you, she
needs to find you attractive?
- [Johnny] She has got to like you.
And when they gave you your money
when they give you the money
you know they like you.
when they help you and listen to you
be there for you, time aid and assist.
You know, they like you
that's the ones you keep on your side,
If They don't like you.
They, when it come time for
a touchdown, they're not
they're not, they're
going to fumble the ball.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- [Johnny] Nobody can duplicate my style.
And my swag been around
for a long, long time
all over the country.
And I go way back with
every pimp you might know.
I know every pimp in the country
and my name is impeccable.
You mention, Kim Johnny Dollar,
They gonna say, that's a good guy.
That's my man.
And never be no dirt.
(swallows drink)
- [Interviewer] What's
was the most important
lesson you've learned
in your life?
- [Johnny] The most important lesson
I've learned?
Mess with the chick that
like you, not the one
you like, the one you like you
going to accept all tiny stuff
out of it.
And y'all know it's true.
You're going to have to accept
all kinds of stuff, that
You never accepted off another chick,
and it might be another chick
right next door that like you
and is going to do everything
and keep you right.
But you'd rather mess with
this pretty girl over here.
That's giving you all kinds of problems,
you dig?.
That's how the world goes.
Not just with the Pimp and the whole game,
A lot of people have
a tendency that right.
People, they supposed to cheat right.
This loyal and dedicated.
They overlook it and they
treat the other people, right.
That mean I'm no good, no
intentions and that's life.
But you know, I have to
mess with the right girls.
You know
- [Interviewer] You've been
doing this a long time.
I'm sure you've, you've
seen some crazy things.
- [Johnny] I've seen crazy things.
- So tell me, tell me
when you're crazy stories
- I've seen.
Let me tell you the wildest
crazy thing I've ever seen.
You know, I think I've
seen somebody, you know
I've seen gorilla pimps, you
know, I'm a keep it real.
I've seen gorilla pimps,
you know, and I, you know
when I try and step up, you know
so I'm the elder and an old G and a game.
And I mentioned something to him, you know
they tell me to stay at their game.
You know I seeing a man
try and drown a chick
before I've seen a, you
know, I had to really step in
and then they say, I'm
captain save a ho nah.
I saved you.
Cause you woulda got a life.
And he wouldn't be around right now.
And he really thinks
me for that right now.
Every time I see the man,
man, man, I was over there, man.
I didn't know what I was doing.
I tried to drown that chick.
And you stopped me.
Yeah. So things like that,
they do happen in the world.
may
- [Interviewer] What are you proudest of
in your life?
- [Johnny] What Am I proud of?
I'm proud of my achievement..
I'm proud to be here on earth,
you know, from the grace
of God, you know, he's first
from everything, you know
but I'm glad that my achievements,
you know, I own my own company
I don't have to pimp, no more,
I don't have to be mistreated.
You know, I have my own, everything.
I have my own crib, my
own company, you know?
And I'm functioning.
Well, legit money is
nothing like legit money.
You know
- [Interviewer] You don't have to do it,
but you still do
- [Johnny] Why? I have a
lot of girls to help me now.
You know, I ain't gonna
turn down no money.
Cause I deserve it.
You know, by being in the game so long
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And the
game has changed a lot.
- [Johnny] The games changed so much.
- [Interviewer] Yeah. In what ways
has it changed?
- [Johnny] It's changed.
You know, it's changed like a money hall.
Let's make a deal.
You know, a lot of pimps,
you know, they just
there's one to say, they
have a girl, you understand
but you know, they don't have no
they stay in with they
sister, they cousin.
And some, you know, when
you got girls just shows
because they, you go to live like a King.
And that's what I do live
like a King, you know
- [Interviewer] You've
been in love before.
- [Johnny] Absolutely.
Yeah. That's how I learned from the burns.
You know, that's what I
call messing with a chick.
You like, yeah.
- (laughing)
Yeah I've been in love before man.
And when you're in love, you know,
there's no limit
to what you would do.
For your spouse that you with, you know
and a lot of times you do things
which is unforbidden
to the game.
You know what I mean?
That, that, that, that you know it's going
it'll cross you out the game you'd be
out the game, quicker than you came
in the game.
So you gotta be careful watch yourself.
But that's what happened
when you fall in love.
But now I'm in love with
money and success of
life. And of course the man upstairs.
- [Interviewer] So Religion,
religion is important to you.
- [Johnny] Yeah, man,
I believe in God, man.
I never would be, you know, this age
there's been so many places
that have so much knowledge
in his brain.
You know, if I didn't
believe in God, God saves me.
- [Interviewer] And what,
what personality trait do you
possess that helps you do this?
- [Johnny] Just be me,
- [Interviewer] your charm?.
- [Johnny] Yeah. Just be me, you know?
But I've noticed throughout
the lifetime, you know
really in these last 10, 15
years, the world is changing.
You know, sometime you
do stuff with somebody
you know that's not worthy of it,
you know what I mean?
And, and that's what it is.
You know, you gotta mess
with loyal people because
one wrong person, you know,
it's a lot of haters out there.
Now, a lot of people don't like the game.
They don't like you,
they might have had a sister, or a brother
maybe a mother that somebody had
that claims of some pimp.
And he was mispimping, you know
and beating on her and
put a scar on and stuff.
So therefore the son don't like
no pimp he ever seen is a problem
you know what I mean?
And it's a problem.
So you got to keep it on the down low.
You know, I don't use your name.
I don't pump no Mo, but
I know the game very well
and could come out of retirement
anytime with Olympia speed.
- [Interviewer] What do
you think most squares
don't understand about the game?
You know, cause a lot, a lot of
a lot of people make assumptions.
- [Johnny] Well, you know, a lot of them,
you know, they just period
you know, they, they, they,
I tell them hate the game.
Don't hate the player.
Cause you know, I'm telling you
because a lot of them just don't like it.
And that's the simple reason
why they didn't had a sister
or brother or something
and somebody maybe took advantage of them.
You know, probably wasn't even
a pimp in the whole thing.
But it's, you know
the drugs is so cold
out here in this world.
Now, you know, you have
everybody, you know
they might not want to admit
it, but they got people
in that family that do this
and do that and do this.
You know what I mean?
And they're just not the same.
You don't even know who they is anymore.
Have you ever met anybody?
You just don't know who they is anymore.
You know them all the, your whole life.
And now all of a sudden they came too.
You don't even know who they are anymore.
That happens.
- And drugs are a real problem.
- Yeah. Everybody have family
members like that, man.
That's easy.
They were used to be good as gold.
They used to have good jobs and all that.
Now the sudden you see them a year
or two later and they're,
and they smoking somewhere.
They're standing at the
doorway with shoelaces
smoking just a whole
different person, jug games.
Cold Jack and I only drink
champagne and smoke weeds.
You know, I might drink
a beer every now and then
but he can't drink and think too.
And you have to stay
thinking your brain is
this is a computer here, Latin knowledge.
They call it ism in the pimp game.
- All right, Johnny,
thank you so much for sharing your story.
Absolutely. And I wish
you the best of luck.
- And God Bless you, man. Let us pray
Church on the move.
Let us pray.
Pimp Johnny dollar
international ACE caliber
Atlanta, Georgia.